I created the network I have the most
watched show on TV I will not tolerate
disrespect you've lost a damn mind
you're fine at your joy and playing this
woman I could really see it I have to
ask the fans seem to never let go of
hoping for a Sex in the City movie what
can we tell him about that why why do
they never lose hope about it they they
never I think this is what what I think
people love about shows like Sex in the
City and filthy riches strong characters
you know real strong characters and this
is a new chapter this is another strong
character so I'm really enjoying with
many more moves I can tell by your
clapping that you're excited for filthy
rich talk to me about how your character
fits into this wealthy southern
religious family give us a little a
little preview of the premise of the
show well I'll start with why I was
interested in doing the show that the
premise is basically in many ways
Kim's characters like a Southern
Christian Oprah she is probably her
character is the most watched lifestyle
show in America and she has a really
strong faith number one network oh
absolutely
and and what happens without giving
anything away and what interested me in
telling this story and the show is our
country as we all know lacks empathy in
any way between any people everything's
white black right wrong and and I love
the idea of having this format to put
this woman and the crosshairs of every
situation in America right now and see
how she handles it through faith and
she's gonna make mistakes as we all do
and I think that's important you've been
listening to my interviews oh I love her
she's a she's a an iron hand in a velvet
glove that's the best way that I could
yes and she came from a generation of
women who brought themselves up
she didn't come from much but she had
self belief she had faith she had family
and that's what's brought her to where
she is today I love that and I believe
both of you thoroughly everything you
say talk to me a little bit about your
big hair and costumes and stuff like
that does that add to your ability to
play this character big hair southern
hair well I think the thing that we love
about her is that she you know she
started as a life style host so that's
how to set your table that's how to
access in rural Louisiana from nothing
from nothing the VHS record there you
got it but she likes to keep up you know
the the latest fashions of etc but there
is an old-world charm to market Monroe
she loves but the things about life that
those little details she loves to cook
she loves to entertain there's a
wonderful feeling of her giving and
welcoming which is in the south which is
one of the reasons why New Orleans place
such a big part of our show because
that's what it's like there it really is
it's like one big family now you said
you want to just have a good time work
with good people and as that played a
part in you picking this role have you
put that it plays a part in picking
whatever your the job is you know
especially at this time in my life it's
really one of the big bonds what's your
favorite what's talk to me Katie you
know Cajun louisiana you have a thing
just say i eat everything but dill and
watermelon okay well what's your problem
with dill and watermelon what's wrong
disgusting okay
appointment no i don't well if there's
too many bones in the fish i get a
little concerned but besides that I'm
good
I'll try I'll try it how about on the
cooking side of the Cajun stuff did you
guys ponder into that area at all my
gosh yeah I almost
was a chef before choosing this career
so I love food and I love to cook oh
yeah I wanted to do that and well yeah
we cooked and her character knows how to
hunt and fish and clean fish she's she
really she'sshe's a well-rounded gal
[Music]